البدايه بالجاردن البريطانيه التي اشارت
الى ان الامراض تنتشر في مدينه رفح
المقتضى بالسكان مع اضطرار سكان غزه الى
النزوح نحو الجنوب ومن المتوقع استفحال
الازمه في الايام المقبله مع اصرار القوات
الاسرائيليه على توسيع توغلها في خانيونس
قال الكاتب توماس فريدمان في مقاله
بنيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ان اسرائيل تخسر
الان على عده جبهات فقد خسرت حرب السرد
على غزه ومثلت امام محكمه العدل الدوليه
كما انها تفقد القدره على الحفاظ على
امنها وتخسر ايضا على جبهه الاستقرار
الاقليمي حيث باتت هدفا لحماس وحزب الله
والحوثيين والميليشيات الشيعيه في العراق
وفي الوقت ذاته لا تستطيع تل ابيب كسب
الحلفاء العرب او حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو
للانتصار في الحرب لانها ترفض اعتماد اي
مبادره لرعايه شريك فلسطيني شرعي وذي
مصداقيه طالب مقال في موقع ذاهل
الديمقراطيين في الولايات المتحده بان
يضغطوا من اجل اقامه دوله فلسطينيه وان
يتوصلوا الى اتفاق نووي مع ايران واشار
الموقع الى ضروره ان يصاحب التوصل الى
اتفاق النووي متجدد مع ايران تحرك امريكي
حازم بشان المفاوضات التي تؤدي الى اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه لان احدهما لا يعمل دون
الاخر قالت هارتس الاسرائيليه في افتتاح
حيتها انه يجب على اسرائيل ان تنضم الى
امريكا وبريطانيا في القول نعم للدوله
الفلسطينيه في ظل انضمام المزيد من الدول
الداعمه لهذا التوجه لكن بنيامين نتنياهو
وحكومته المتطرفه وفقا للصحيفه
الاسرائيليه فشلا في استيعاب هذه الصحوه
السياسيه ويبدو ان واشنطن ولندن تدركان ان
من المستحيل العوده الى المماطله
الدبلوماسيه بشان الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني قال الكاتب اورلي الولاي في
مقاله به يدعوت احرونوت الاسرائيليه ان
بنيامين نتنياهو يلجا الى التسويف
والمماطله في الوقت على امل عوده دونالد
ترامب لرئاسه امريكا ما يمثل بالتالي
مفتاح بقائه السياسي ويرى الكاتب ان ترامب
يتمتع بالاعجاب في اسرائيل لانه نقل
السفاره الامريكيه الى القدس لكنها خطوه
ثبت انها جوفا وفق قوله ختام هذا العرض
بمقال في مجله فورن افيرز راى ان الشرق
الاوسط يواجه لحظه عصيبه بسبب اراقه
الدماء المروعه في غزه وقد ينزلق الى مزيد
من الازمات واضاف المقال ان الدول الكبيره
في الشرق الاوسط وحدها القادره على اصلاح
وصياغه نظام اقليمي للمنطقه وبناء مستقبل
مختلف لان النشاط العسكريه والدبلوماسيه
الامريكي لم يغرس
[موسيقى]
الثقه y